>>> YO, LIL PUMP.
SAM ROCKWELL, THIS IS CERTAIN,
GUY.
HE'S A CHARACTER ACTOR, WE BOTH
LOVE.
HE'S VERY UNDERAPPRECIATED.
THIS IS FOR OUR BOY, STANLEY.
HIT IT.
♪♪♪
♪ TUCCI GANG
TUCCI GANG
TUCCI GANG ♪
♪ TUCCI GANG
TUCCI GANG
SOME OF YOU ♪
DON'T KNOW THE NAME
BUT THAT'S THE GUY
♪ FROM "THE HUNGER GAMES"
"TRANSFORMERS"
"THE LAST KNIGHT"
"BEAUTY AND THE BEAST" AND ♪
♪ "SPOTLIGHT."
WRITER AND DIRECTOR OF
"BIG NIGHT"
♪ TUCCI GANG
TUCCI GANG
TUCCI GANG ♪
♪ TUCCI GANG
TUCCI GANG
TUCCI GANG ♪
SOME OF YOU ♪
DON'T KNOW THE NAME
BUT THAT'S THE GUY
♪ FROM "THE HUNGER GAMES"
MARRIED FELICITY BLUNT
SISTER OF EMILY BLUNT
MY MAN TOOCH IS WITH ♪
A BLUNT
TUCCI GANG
TUCCI GANG ♪
32 YEARS IN THE BIZ
I AM A BIG FAN OF HIS ♪
♪ I GOT MAD RESPECT
FOR HIS RANGE
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN DR. STRANGE.
"THE DEVIL WEARS PRADA" ♪
♪ WAS SICK
IF YOU DON'T LIKE SAM
YOU ARE A DICK
HE ADDS VALUE TO YOUR FLICK ♪
♪ IF YOU DON'T LIKE SAM
YOU A BITCH
HE DID TWO MOVIES WITH STREEP
I WANT TO NAME MY SON ♪
♪ TWO GS
DID YOU KNOW MY MAN
HAD A COOKBOOK
AND HE WAS THE CO-OWNER ♪
♪ OF A RESTAURANT ♪
♪ TUCCI GANG
TUCCI GANG
TUCCI GANG ♪
♪ SOME OF YOU
DON'T KNOW THE NAME
BUT THAT'S THAT GUY FROM
"THE HUNGER GAMES" ♪
♪ "TRANSFORMERS"
"THE LAST KNIGHT"
"BEAUTY AND THE BEAST" ♪
♪ AND "SPOTLIGHT"
WRITER AND DIRECTOR OF
"BIG NIGHT"
♪ TUCCI GANG
TUCCI GANG
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> OH, NO.
NO, NO.